[Music]
thank you
so some breaking news and I've been
working on this story all day coming up
FYI takes over the Sky Sports News
Channel on one of the biggest days of
the year for football
[Music]
and two FYI viewers stopped the city for
the countryside with stunt riding
[Music]
foreign
hi there this is FYI the Weekly News
show where we bring you all the latest
info on all the big stories and the
thing that everyone's been talking about
this week is football every January
football has a month-long chance for
winter 11 clubs to buy and sell top
players moving them from one club to
another some of the world's biggest
players have been transferred for
millions of pounds Chelsea Football Club
actually broke the British transfer
record by signing Argentinian midfielder
Enzo Fernandez for a whopping 107
million pounds wow well no one's more
crazy about football than fya's Braden
so we arranged our own transfer we took
over the Sky Sports news coverage of
deadline day
foreign
this is deadline day FYI takeover
I'm here at Sky Sports to go behind the
scenes to find out how some of the
world's biggest transfers get done and
make breaking news on TV and across
social media
so the transfer window is a period of
time where football clubs can use their
money to sign players from all around
the world to strengthen their squad
right let's get this production meeting
nice to see you both makes a pleasant
change that you're here on time uh
Braden's joining us today are you going
to take over
[Music]
Tottenham line we think what are you
working on something very serious
something very big but we'll find out
soon you can tell us no absolutely not
nothing nothing at all
very serious business it is a production
meeting we need to know what you're
working on don't want you stealing my
story
sometimes it can be the Turning Point
within a Club season for example if
they're fighting relegation sometimes
they can bring in place to keep them up
and fight that and sometimes it can help
people win the league
so what's going on over here well we do
all the graphics for deadline day so all
your graphics go on the big screen at
the back yeah
I think today we're making you sign for
City
that's awesome
[Music]
this is the one transversial FYI
so here we go good afternoon welcome to
a transfer show with a difference this
deadline day FYI takeover are they
darnish and Braden here to bring us the
very latest transfer news
foreign
every day on the transfer show we go
around all 20 Premier League clubs
carvey's usually standing there would
you want to give it a go I'd love to
give it a go well Brayden let's go
around the clubs let's do it 10 seconds
just checking you can all hear me okay
Mike keep an eye out Braden's expecting
some huge breaking news very soon start
your move on four and mix number one
target has been Enzo hold it there
Braden has breaking news Brayden what
have you got so some breaking news and
I've been working on this story all day
and if you were looking in the Press you
would think that Michaela Modric was
going to Arsenal however for 88.5
million pounds and on an eight and a
half year deal Michaela Modric is a
Chelsea player fantastic deal done how
did I do
you got the job Carvey out get him out
in
I've really enjoyed myself today this is
a big football fan and watch it on TV
it's almost like my dream to be on here
I mean I've got to have my say today and
I've also got to do some breaking news
it's been such an amazing day
[Music]
nice one Braden so we've all heard of
the World Cup but did you know there's
also a green football pup
like many sports football can be bad for
the environment football grounds use
loads of water and high energy
floodlights not to mention the thousands
of fans who travel to matches creating
waste and carbon emissions which can
contribute to climate change but good
news Premier League football clubs and
the local schools are fighting back
hoping to win the green football cup so
this is how it works clubs and schools
have to score the most green goals by
doing something good for the environment
like eating veggie meals or cycling and
walking instead of using a car each
action gets them closer to winning the
Green football cup so far Manchester
United a tip to win we headed to Saint
Alphonsus Primary School in Manchester
who were last year's winners for some
inspiration on what we can all do to go
greener
Green football weekend is a campaign
that encourages us all to do green
things by scoring green goals
at the end of the week and the teams
with the most goals come in amazing
prizes
it's not just us kids that are doing it
it's footballers too to score a goal you
do something green like you use a
reusable water bowl eat a veggie meal
instead of a meat on or cycle to school
if you take a picture of yourself doing
this and you upload it to the green
football weekend page and then add it to
your team's goals
the toaster has to be counted yet but
last year we went with over 16 000 girls
what do you think we should do to make
schools Greener if they could
like plant wild flowers bees waffs
everything pollen that they can get I
think that'll help a lot I think our
school should do a fundraiser so we can
raise more money and add solar panels to
The Reef hiker I think about one of the
things that schools could do to be
greener is meet free meals maybe we
could like compost that would be good
for the school too we should just start
putting posters up saying don't drive
cars try ride bikes try walk try drug
run if you can they should start using
electric school buses because it will
help stop pollution because normal
school buses use gas who do you think
should be responsible for reducing
carbon emissions in my feelings I feel
like everyone should be responsible do
you think there should be more support
to make our schools Greener yes I think
the government should do more and give
money to schools because if we all do a
little bit
um it will really help I should start
right now because
um if you started it might be too late
and it will get worse and worse
[Music]
this picture that we found online it's
said to be a magnified image of a cat's
tongue and it looks like it's made out
of lots of smaller tongues but is this a
fake picture find out later
we heard that the former education
Minister Nadeem zahawi who we've
interviewed on FYI has been sacked by
prime minister Rishi sunak he was fired
from his job in the conservative party
after breaking the ministerial code a
set of rules that all government
ministers have to follow Mr zahawi did
not tell government officials while he
was Chancellor and in charge of the UK
tax system that he was actually under
investigation for not paying his taxes
properly tax is something that everyone
pays to the government to fund things
like schools hospitals and Roads the
amount of money people have to pay is
worked out as a percentage from the
total amount they earn from their jobs
Mr zahal we had to pay more tax along
with the penalty
so you may have heard a lot of talk
about walkout Wednesday you might have
been affected by it so we've been
checking this out it was basically the
biggest day of strikes for 10 years
teachers train drivers bus drivers
lecturers and many more people refuse to
come into work more than 500 000 people
went on strike across the UK they
believed they should be getting paid
more as food clothes electricity gas and
petrol all become more expensive however
the government that controls their wages
so they can't afford the workers demands
tens of thousands of teachers went on
strike which led to the closure of more
than 50 percent of our schools London
was the worst hit with an estimated 250
000 people stuck at home because their
schools are sharp and with workers and
the government both refusing to back
down we can expect more strikes in the
next few months including school
closures children we have one chance an
education
that's why we're here today because we
know the reality
of the funding within our schools
[Music]
are you ready for this okay let it rip
the world can be a confusing place so
maybe we can help
I'm gonna take us back in time for a
quick history lesson
from the origins of the royal family to
healthy eating we've been investigating
well there's no doubt that what we
choose to eat has a huge impact on our
health just take a look at this
pretty cool right we've explored our
virtual planet to find the answers
far more dangerous than volcanoes are
earthquakes which can cause the ground
beneath our feet to shake and open up
large cracks in the Earth's surface
we'll ask how we can all spot fake news
hello everyone today's headlines
strange butt-like creatures have been
spotted living on the moon and what can
we do with all the stuff we throw away
we're told recycling is a solution but
is it working I need an expert hi Dan hi
Tilly plus how can we stay safe on the
internet just like in the real world
there are dangers when we're online that
we need to look out for
[Music]
and should we be worried about disasters
the closest most of us will ever get to
something like this is when we go and
see a disaster movie
so don't worry if you just don't get it
we've got you sorted check out our news
explainers on Sky Kids On Demand and Via
our webpage thus dot news forward slash
FYI
check this out researchers have made
shape-shifting robots that can turn
themselves into liquid
the robots can also jump climb over
walls and even split in half so that the
two pieces can work together to move
objects they're also magnetic and can be
used to conduct electricity which in
turn allows them to be controlled
scientists hope that one day they can be
used to help solve medical and
Engineering problems
[Music]
so did you know that one in three
children who live in cities never get
into the countryside wow well I guess
that's understandable because of the
cost of living crisis and money is very
tight for a lot of families right now
the London International Horse Show gave
members of ebony Horse Club from Brixton
the chance to spend a day in the
countryside to see a side of horse
riding they hadn't experienced before
[Music]
foreign
so guys Welcome to our headquarters so I
don't know if you know anything about us
but we're the devil's Horsemen we are
the biggest supplier of courses for film
and TV across the world who's ready then
follow me so this is part of our subtle
collection they're all different periods
these are medieval Saddles this is one
of our sheds and part of our our
Carriage collection so we have about
over 900 in stock we see the double
decker buses in London this is the
original double decker bus this Carriage
here is built by us this is actually
built for The Witcher that's Wonder
Woman's horse
we're here to see some stunt demos and I
really hope I'm going to get to try some
of them myself
what's really interesting about studies
you always see the end products so you
either see it in a live show or you see
it in the film and TV shows and you
don't see what Beginnings are the
training you don't see what comes from
the rider that's like the really
interesting Parts three two one go I
accomplished one of my fears actually
like turning around on the horse's neck
like laying on my back as well like yeah
it was very interesting news I feel very
confident on these because they're not
real horses and it's nice to do more
complex tricks and see how professionals
train
and then from there they're just very
inspiring people and that himself when
he was um encountering us around the
arena in the carriage lean to the right
I was absolutely shocked and stunned
that it was actually breathtaken
honestly especially when he went faster
they said oh leave from yeah
it was nice it was really nice I think
it's wonderful but you get to kind of
have people from the countryside people
from the inner city and be able to bring
all of those people together I do
believe that inner city kids can do this
for a living like 100 and I think some
of them are already kind of like looking
at it and catching the bug
I'll definitely choose this as a career
today was amazing and it was really fun
to see a different side of the bus
industry okay Sunday yeah
much better
if you have a story and you want to
report on FYI get in touch via our
webpage or even better get your teacher
to set up an FYI News Club at your
school members get the chance to report
for us we'll even help you film Your Own
Story you can watch and discuss the
latest episodes with free resources
every week
have you seen this the face of a bear
has been found on the surface of Mars no
way
astronomers from the University of
Arizona took this snap using high
resolution cameras on board the NASA
spacecraft
the Bear's eyes are two craters formed
by asteroids hitting the planet's
surface while a collapsed Hill has made
its nose Q they say the shape of the
best head could be the outline of
another larger crater
[Music]
so did you think that this social media
post of a magnified cat's tongue was
fake or fat it's fact it looks like it's
made up of lots of smaller tongues
because it's covered in backward facing
papillae these tough structures are used
to clean the cat's fur
[Music]
well that's it for this week see you
next time don't forget for more info on
the news check out all our shows and
videos on our webpage bye
[Music]